Time. The camera shuts off.
You just say this offhand comment and we're just like, Whoa, shut them out.
They like, can you like explain it next, next episode on trust,
trace Christian to be like this one time I accidentally stole the declaration of
independence. Totally funny story. Can't talk about it then. We'll come on,
come on. Set the scene early, hijack the boat. Wow.
How do you nearly millionaire guy in the river? Thames had like a yacht.
Uh, they had a party on a, me and my Stony and Fred crashed it.
John could Ellie like cast off, nearly cast off.
I was really drunk and I found my way into the engine room with this.
You don't just find your way into the engine room activity. It's just some 24.
He's on the Eastern espionage mission.
I'm in a steam GG where I cannot talk about I'm a nice person.
You had a shot of whiskey and found myself in a mic. That's kind of, what is,
it was one kilometer from Emily six on the river.
I could see my six from the boat. I love,
how am I six? You know, this very secretive thing. It's like,
that's the building [inaudible] building. It's like, Oh, there it is.
God. I feel,
I love how you made the most interesting story into the most throwaway tip
along the times where I used to rule Kazak Stan as well.
Classic stories for me, Chris,
I accidentally became the King of Catholics. There'll be a bit, one day.
They're very good perk to promote him. Chris, Chris King of Kansas,
Chris Paul, Chris King of Casper, because he's done too much.
And now he's bought in. It's been scamming people under my name.
[inaudible] I'm a Brown in Japan.
You're kidding me.
It was a Facebook page of a screenshot and it had Chris's face on it with the
logo as like the banner from the fall.
And it was like this one look, you were like, Oh, that's Chris's Facebook page.
But then when you look closely,
Chris Christopher bull rat of a bra,
a Brown in Japan.
And apparently if you get this message, one $5,000, $5,000,
you've just been scared,
Catholics done.
I wish I wish my view is for that creative to come up with with those kinds of
things. I had a Brown in Japan.
Do you know what the worst,
the most awkward thing I've ever had was in that kind of sense?
Is that a one time basis? Really?
Back when I started it must have like maybe like 80 K sub. So, you know,
still quite small. And uh, one time I got a Skype friend,
dad from somewhat backwards, Skype was like, not a boomer. I know. It's like,
Oh gee, now I had it. And I was like, okay, sure.
What's this is it back when you would just be like, it. Yeah.
I'll just add anyone. Yeah. And they were like,
why aren't you replying to my messages when I added them? And I'm like,
who are you? What are you, why did you I'm like, why did you,
and then you're like, why did you block me in your other account? I'm like,
well, what, w w what other accounts? So what happened was turns out, right?
There's someone had been pretending to be me on a YouTube channel. Right. Right.
And they have, and so I got on call with them because I was like, it. Why not?
Let's go. Let's just see what's going on. So I called them up and they're like,
they were like, absolutely panicking. So I'm like, all right, hold on.
What's going on? Tell him, tell him what's going on here. Like, um,
I was dating you and then we, you stopped messaging me.
And I'm like, you were dating me. And I'm like, this is, this is news to me. Uh,
and they were like, yeah, I met you through your YouTube channel.
And then they linked me my YouTube channel. Right.
And it was someone who had like, Pokemon, like Ruby plastered,
all over their thing called like Seadog VA. Right. And they, they,
they were American doing a terrible British accent pretending to be me.
So I was like, huh. So you think this is me? And they were like, yeah.
They said that this was your second channel. I'm like,
you have to be kidding. They thought they were dating because this guy,
because this guy apparently was talking to her often and I'm like, do,
did he sound like me? And she's like, yeah. Yeah, he did.
So I looked on the YouTube videos. He sounded American as. How did he sound?
Like, Hey, what's up guys? It's Seadog VA here,
back with another Pokemon. Ruby let's play. And it was like, totally.
I was like, I was dumbfounded at how,
because at one part I felt sorry for this woman, because she was hysterical.
But on the other I'm like, how do you fall?
I feel like you're going to lose your credit card at some point to some, like,
you know, I was like dumbfounded. I'm like, all right. I calmed her down.
I was like, listen. Right. I did not.
That could have been the saga reach out to me
because they were clearly like, you know, dumb,
you know, I don't like to call my, my view is done, but, but I'll say,
but listen, Chris, if you fall for that, you're dumb this. Yeah.
If a guy has a ground on us, their profile picture,
they should be bells in your head as to it not being me. Well,
maybe you call it like the shoulders. You have to feel. Okay.
I feel sorry for someone who would, if they fell for something,
if they were pretend to be me,
but there are certain levels of disbelief where I'm like,
this has gotta be on you. This, this is, you know,
it wasn't even a British accent. That's where I draw the line.
Wasn't even British to even watch my car,
the amount of videos there are people like impersonating me for like funny
videos. Some of them are quite good, but there's so many where it,
doesn't not even remotely sound like me and people are falling. Yeah.
For videos. How so they'll go on discord servers with the name Seadog VA.
And they'll go in and they'll start talking and like a fake discord.
And then sometimes my discord, other discourses too late,
they go into voice and stuff. Right. And a random service,
random service is for like funny videos. Some are quite funny actually. Yeah.
And they'll, they'll just do a really bad British accent. And everyone be like,
Oh my God, it's sea dog VA. Oh my God. It's him. And I'm sitting here at home.
Like.
Seriously, that's all it takes. Oh,
apparently there's like a demographic of your fans who watch your videos have
muted. Everyone. Everyone who is British sounds like condom.